[音楽]
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
同志社大学商学部で非常勤講師をしている
柳です
普段は広告会社に働いています
大切なのは何になるかより何をやるか
皆さん
将来の夢
どういう風に考えていますか
あんなものになりたい
こんなものなりたい
たくさんの想いを思っているかと思います
ご覧ください
こちらが今年の新小学生
小学1年生で将来就きたい職業の
ランキングです
いやー本当に様々なものになりたいっ
子どもたちはすごく思っています
皆さんはどうですか
自分は何になりたいか
自分は何になるべきか
自分はなになれるのか
そういうふうに考えて
何かにならなければならないと思ってませ
んか
今日お話しすることはこの何かになら
なければならないと思ってそれを
プレッシャーに思って色々感っていう人
たちに僕自身の話をしたいと思います
もちろん
なりたいものがそこにあってそれに向けて
努力している人はとうとういいですそして
なりたいものが見つかった人
これは本当にラッキーだと思います
ですが小さい頃がなりたいものたくさん
あったのですけど
統計データによるとほとんどの人は
なりたいものが見つからないということで
悩んでそうです
大切なのは何になるかより何をやるか
僕は埼玉県で生まれたんですけども小さい
頃から本当にやりたいことがいっぱいあり
ました
なりたいものがいっぱいありました
あんなことになれたらいいな将来こういう
ふうになれたらいいなってずっと
たくさんのことを思いながら過ごし
大学京都に来て京都でまたやりたいことを
やりながら
どんどんどんどん自分のなりたいものって
いうのが増えていきました
でもそうこうしているうちに就職活動が
始まります業界研究を言ったりするんです
けどその時に陥ったのはこれです
何かにならなければならないと
こういう風に考えて
頭が止まってました
そんななんか
みた
人形浄瑠璃0
これ見たことありますか
人形が豊かにコミュニケーションしている
でも実はこれって
この裏側にいる人が動かしてるんですよね
これを見てはこれだと思いました
裏方になればいいんだと思ったんです
協会研究しているうちの高校会社を選び
ました
僕は広告マンになりたいなんて全く思って
ませんでしたですけどもやりたいこと
いっぱいありました
広告会社の立ち位置って紅葉の中に対して
こうね
ここにいるんです
企業が世の中に対して
届けたいもののここにいて
彼らがコミュニケーションを考えてきそう
なんです
いやーこれって
この企業団体を複数やっていけば
やっぱり自分が好意なりたいものたくさん
あったものっていうのを一つも慣れないん
だけど広告マンですから
全部やれるかもしれないと思いました
全部なれないが全部やりたいと思ってここ
会社に入りま
今では
400を超える企業団体の
コミュニケーション考えて
企業そして世の中に対してのことという
ことを思って
広告をやっているうちに
たくさんをも描いていたやりたいこと
全部やれました
国内外でさまざまな賞もん
ラッキーなことにいただくことも出来まし
た
そんなことをして40歳
いや40歳と言うとあと20年で
生活終わりまー今の音もっと伸びてます
けど
海外の顔が熱の入った時に
ビルクリントンさん
この人の話を聞いて僕は自分のこれから
20年をどう生きていけばいいのか
深く深く思ったのです
元大統領が何を言うんだろうということで
もたくさんの人たちが
その場所に
お集まりました
本当に
すごい楽しい話をしてくるんですよ紛争の
話とかいっぱいしてどんどん引き込まれて
いきます
僕はこの満員の席の2階の端っこで見てた
んですけれども
いやどんどん話に引き込まれていくんです
よね
あり話がうまへすごいなぁと思って見てた
んですけど最後に彼がこういうふうにいう
わけです
コミュニケーターたちは今後20年がどう
なっていくかという面で世界に強い影響を
与えると思う
だからこそベストを尽くして考えてほしい
あなたたちがいま何をなすべきかおお
会場には全世界から広告に関わる人たちが
集まっています
僕は涙が止まりませんでした
隣の人も涙が止まりませんでした
みんな立って
スタンディングオーベーションです
自分ができることは何か
自分がやるべきことは何か
教えてもらえたんですね
ヒョン10歳になって会社生活あと20年
と
ヒューもおっさんです
このサンタンタイミングで僕はやるべき
ことを見つけました
広告は創る未来
どんな未来なんだろうってすごく思ってい
ましたきっとこんな未来だと思ってました
みてください
様々なもの広告が飛び出してきてますよね
いやすごい世界です
っていうのが
広告が創る未来
何でしょうか
いやこういう未来もあるかも知れませんで
も
きっと我々
広告が作るべき未来
というのがあると思い
ではこれです
人と地球に優しい世界
人と地球にやさしい未来を創ることが我々
が作るべき
未来
いうふうに思いました
広告とスキルで社会課題に異論
今49なんですけど9年間
思い出ずっと走ってきています
皆さん合谷どんなイメージを持っています
か
最近はこんな調査結果も出ています
社会的課題の取り組みを行う企業に対する
印象てコミュニケーションをしていく中で
例えば社会からに取り組みを見せていく
ことによって
それってプラスになっていく企業として後
消費の価値もひょっとした一人で上がって
くるかもしれないということなんです
広告主にとって良いこと
あと世の中にとって良いこと
この2つって成立するんです
そうしたコミュニケーションをつくって
夜中に出していく
これが僕がやりたいこと
これまでたくさんのことをやらせて
いただきました
もうたくさんあるので
たくさん消化できないんでね今日は一つ
だけ
tica 離れ
すごい深刻なんですよ本当にあの新聞読ん
でても日か離れとか科学者になりたくない
とかどうしたらいいのか子供たちが理科や
数学が嫌いっていうのは
こともあるかもしれないですけど今教員で
教える教員の数が減ってきたりとか学部も
高額受けよりが理系の学部がどんどん減っ
てきたりとかしているという風に僕が聞い
ています
これを変えていかないと技術立国日本
やばいです
そう思って
やったことなんですけど
よくいます
子どもたちに科学に興味を持ってもらい
たい
これに対してこう答えます
子どもたちが好きなもので買う分興味持っ
てもらえばいいんじゃないか
例えば子供たちが好きなお菓子で
科学に興味を持っとなり企画がやれたら
いいんじゃないか
そんなこと思って
行ったことがあります
人間はソフトキャンディキャラ目で1粒
300m ってこの講座
じゃあこれが
ロケットだったらひとつの何メートルと
思うんですか
これがやりたかったんです
燃料はぷっちょ
これを使ってロケットが取るとか
様々な原因の人たち jaxa の方も
低めでやらせていただきましたもう実験字
型の日々です苦節2ねああ
て完成したのがこれです
燃料タンクにはぷっ長は20つつ待って
ます
キャンディロケットプロジェクトと名付け
ました
こんな言葉も載せてます
キャンディーハイブリッドロケットを取ら
打ち上げるそんな馬鹿馬鹿しいていい人が
いるかもしれないそれでも多くの偉大な
発明を最初からそう3皿だけじゃないこれ
は人類の新たな扉を開く可能性の本気で
挑戦する努力と成功すれば世界初夢を忘れ
な大人だ力すべての人々
いうメッセージを込めて
子どもたちの前で
れにしました
これねあのロケット弾の燃料タンクに打ち
入れるとこ見てますよね
プッシ
縁上がりました2回あったんですけど2回
とも成功です
でこんなニュースは子どもそこで見てた
子どもたちだけじゃなくてさまざまなとこ
に伝播するわけですねいろんなニュースで
取り上げたり世界でも30カ国で取り上げ
ていただいたりとかが話題になることだっ
たが売り上げがあり
人間の燃料とロケットネイルが=なって
すごい活気て籠なんですよ何でも学会で
先生に発表していただきたいとかしました
wd
企業世の中宇宙会もうトリプルですよ
のとって素敵なこと
っていうのを実現できてすごくうれしかっ
た
そんなことですねたくさんやってきました
でそんなことをやってきたんですけど
なんか広告の理由だけじゃ無理だなぁと
広告とまた別のとこでの活動っていうのも
様々なことをやらせていただいています
プロボノです
自分の専門性を生かしてボランティア活動
する行為また人自身です
今日ご紹介するのは一般社団法人 get
in touch 北リジーさせていたで
得なんですけどダイバーシティ兄
インクルージョンとかなんかちょっとまあ
難しい言葉だなぁと思ってまず保存社会
っての目指してやるということでやってる
んですけど
本当に生き辛さあを感じている皆さんが
いらっしゃって
それぞれがそれぞれと社会と向き合ってい
ます
んですけどもきっと
マイノリティって
重ねていけばマジョリティになるんじゃ
ないかと思うんです
なので
ここで向き合うんじゃなくて横のつながり
をつくって社会と向き合う
このためのエンターテインメント利用する
っていう考え方で僕ら動いています
世界自閉症
啓発で4月2日なんですかこの日は世界中
が多くなりますここも自閉症だけじゃなく
てさまざま糸 mt も方モデルファ
そして
レインボープライドここにも様々な前に
友人の方に出てもらうそしてみんなで社会
と向き合っていくっていう活動
今やらせていただいています
10分の麺を作ったり映画を作ったり
舞台をやったり様々な活動
エンターテインメントですねを通じて社会
と向き合うということをやっています
広告とスキルで社会課題に異論
広告で培ったスキルっていうのを使って
社会課題に挑んでいることです
や社会数の数だけ仕事があり
それだけ僕にはやりがいがあります
どうですか
皆さん将来年目
自分は何になりたいか自分は何になるべき
か自分は何になれるのか
暫時がらめになってないですか
何かにならなければならない
そんなことないんです
もっと堅苦しくなく
何かをやろうっていう気持ちが大事で
その気持ちで
これから自分の未来そして1
社会
地球の未来を考えていきませんか
大切なのは何なに帰るも
何をやるか
何をやりたいと思うか
気持ち
もしよかったらですね
どんなことをやっていても必ず社会党
まあね我々生きていたら
向き合いますよね
自分が社会に対して
やれることの挑戦をしてもらえたらなと
思います
社会貢献をしていくの専門家だけないって
いうことじゃないです
僕はそれ気づいてのは40歳なんてから
です
自分がやりたいと思う気持ちがあれば
やれることなんですそれは年齢は関係ない
です
自分がやりたいと思ったときに
やれば
いいのかな
何かになるよりやりたいと思う気持ち
僕は49剤です
僕からしたら皆さんも未来です
一緒に
人と
急に優しい世界
未来を
作っていってください
[拍手]